the time for talking is over it's trying
to push bunnies
you're flying eggs are pretty impressive
mr. Eggman but let's face it you'll
never catch me hon fidence a fool's
substitute for intelligence
[Music]
that's not good
Sonic I don't you got the SuperSpeed and
everything but Matty and I totally
defense this is probably gonna get blown
up pretty much yeah
don't worry I know exactly what to do I
[Applause]
was not expecting that but I was
expecting not to expect something so it
doesn't count
I'm Sonic a little blue ball of super
energy in an extremely handsome package
and in order to save my planet I had to
come to yours where am I
what yours it is the rock president 20
minutes ago an energy surge knocked out
power across the entire Pacific
Northwest who's there why are you hiding
out in my garage the entire military is
after me
good morning my rural chump I'm going to
give you five seconds to tell me what it
is oh my god stop the car right now the
world's largest rubber band ball we
gotta see it no this is not some fun
family road trip Yeah right
it was lame gift shop let's go though
you can lay low here for a while so what
are we gonna do now
let me show you how it's done so should
we get out of here yeah time to go you
think you won't get away from me Oh huge
you've got car insurance right
about to die
no but thank you for asking
[Music]
how are you not dead I have no idea
[Applause]
[Music]
and you throw your life away for this
silly little alien he's my friend
good times
power that was an illegal left by the
way and I'm using it to protect
glad
with the blue
so you're supposed to be Tom's best
friend that he won't shut up about well
I don't see the appeal
that is very gross
[Music]